hey youtubers is Charlie so they just
revealed what the official title is for
episode 7 the force awakens so this
video is gonna be a breakdown of that
and what I think it means about the
action of the movie as well as when
they're releasing the first trailer
hello to any new people - if you're just
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Star Wars videos so be sure to
subscribe to get everything and please
leave me all your requests for bonus
videos starting off though with the most
obvious things about the title 1 it's
about the force not just Jedi or Sith
some of you might remember the EU novel
of the unifying force I do think that
that's a little bit relevant even though
a lot of the EU got pushed to the side
it does a good job of explaining that
there are two sides to the force
there's the synth and then there's the
Jedi good and evil just depends on your
perspective there are a lot of rumors
about what Mark Hamill is gonna be doing
during the movie they will be following
up on the idea that he is the last of
the Jedi obviously the force awakens
implies a lot of things but the second
big thing about the title they dropped
the episode it's just Star Wars The
Force awakens it's not episode 7 the
force awakens there's a whole lot of
reasons why you drop numbers from a
title but let's talk about what the
force awakens actually says about the
movie the biggest thing a bunch of new
characters are going to learn about the
force bad and good Sith and Jedi I know
a lot of you have already also pointed
out it's kind of funny that technically
the force is already awake like it
already exists Luke Skywalker is gonna
be filling in like the obi-wan Kenobi
figure in the movie although there's
gonna be a bit of a twist on that there
haven't been over it spoilers or
anything like that and that's not what
this video is gonna be about
but since the movies gonna be something
of a transition between the classic
characters and the new cast of
characters like all the young characters
they just cast they're gonna have to
address the issue of Luke Skywalker
being the last of the Jedi so however
they end up showing it we're gonna see a
whole bunch of new characters
discovering the force Luke Skywalker is
just gonna be the point of reference for
all the characters in the movie tying it
back to that novel the unifying force if
you've read that novel just think of
Luke Skywalker is filling in the jason
solo role
that's not exactly what they're doing
but thematically there will be some
parallels if you haven't read that novel
you should definitely check it out
there's a lot of fun I won't post
spoilers about that in the video if you
have read just please use spoiler tags
if you're gonna talk about it
about what happens to Jason solo just
address the issue of transition between
castes yes the original cast you know
the original Trinity is gonna be in the
movie but they'll be passing the torch
so to speak
remember that JJ Abrams is directing the
movie and what is he famous for recently
rebooting Star Trek the Star Wars movies
aren't gonna be reboots they're not
rebooting Star Wars but what Star Trek
did is is passed the torch from the
original cast to the new cast in a
really creative way so they're gonna do
the same type of thing in Episode seven
there have been some liberal spoilers
about the actual plot about how that
happens please use spoiler tags if
you're gonna comment on it below at the
end of the day though as these movies
get on in the sequels episode 8 episode
9 we'll see less of the original cast
and we'll see the story focus more on
the new people the biggest new
characters being Daisy Ridley and John
boyega John boyega is essentially gonna
be our point of entry into the film that
doesn't mean he's gonna be the Luke
Skywalker character that's not what I'm
trying to say it just means that he is
gonna be like the new character to usher
you into this new universe he's gonna be
the point of transition or one of the
points of transition I did you see
interstellar so I'm thinking a lot about
Stanley Kubrick's 2001 Space Odyssey
forced awakening also implies that the
force has some sort of living
consciousness they could go starchild
route and do something like that that's
a little more abstract I don't
necessarily think that's gonna be the
case I don't think the force is gonna
speak itself that sounds a little bit
silly it is a living organism so I think
part of the story's gonna address that
next big thing when the hell is that
trailer gonna come I know everyone wants
to know when are they gonna post footage
right now we know John Williams is
scheduled to record new music just for
the trailer like with a big Orchestra on
the 15th that's next week
once that's done they can pretty much
post the trailer any time they want they
just finished principal photography what
that means is they just finished
shooting with the actors they'll still
do pickups later in the year movie isn't
gonna be out for another year but it's
gonna take that long to do special
effects there are a couple really
important Star Wars related dates coming
up in the next couple of months that I
think they will post footage for or not
for all of them but at least for one of
them first is a year out from the movie
the movie is being released December 18
so the week of Christmas even if you
don't celebrate Christmas is basically
like the third week
end of December since pretty much all
the Star Wars movies have been released
in the spring and this December release
is like a first big change for them they
could just go ahead and post the first
teaser a year out the next date after
that is Star Wars Celebration they will
definitely be airing footage of some
kind at Star Wars Celebration it's too
big of an event for Disney to not do
that that's the second weekend in April
I do have a ticket it's happening in
Anaheim
so regardless of whatever they do
whatever information whatever footage
they post I will be doing all kinds of
videos for it so don't worry about that
if you can't make it the third big date
after that is the age of Ultron release
that's the first weekend in May that's
basically like two weeks after Star Wars
Celebration so those three dates are the
three most likely times that they could
drop the first teaser what I think is
gonna happen is is they'll post a really
short teaser like less than a minute
long this December it might just be a
voiceover it might be Luke Skywalker
giving the obi-wan Kenobi speech over
music typically teasers do not have a
lot of footage from the actual movie
they don't tell you a lot about the
story of the movie it's just something
to get people hooked
I think the first full trailer will
debut at Star Wars Celebration I think
that'll be like two and a half minutes
maybe three minutes it'll have actual
scenes from the movie actual dialogue I
don't think that they'll officially post
that till age of Ultron though I think
they'll attach it to that movie so if
you go to celebration you'll probably
get to see the first official trailer
that'll probably exclusive to Star Wars
Celebration if you can't make it you
probably have to wait til age of Ultron
to see it so the second option is is
they release the first trailer at Star
Wars Celebration then like a day after
that they post it online then they
release a second trailer for age of
Ultron I don't think they're gonna do
that though typically there's about two
months between really big trailers
sometimes they'll release new footage
once a month but that's usually like
really short clips and that's only in
the weeks before a release so again most
likely scenario will see a small teaser
in December than a full trailer at Star
Wars Celebration but now what does
everyone think that they're gonna put in
that first teaser trailer I mentioned it
before but I just feel like giving Luke
Skywalker the obi-wan Kenobi speech from
Episode four over some really mysterious
original music maybe a few landscape
shots would probably be the best thing
they could do the movie is all about the
force so I just feel like it makes sense
that they would use the speech about how
the
force binds the Galaxy together let me
know though what do you think regardless
of when it drops what do you think is
gonna be in that first teaser trailer JJ
Abrams has really unusual creative ways
of revealing information about his
movies like the cryptic Star Wars
pictures addressing all the leaks I have
no doubt he's gonna do the exact same
thing whenever they get ready to post
footage of all the things with all these
new movies that I'm really looking
forward to it's just the prospect of all
the different directors working on all
the different films there's like 30
different comic book films being
released in the next five or six years
that might seem like a lot Marvel is
actually gonna be up to three films per
year by 2017 Star Wars is gonna get to
the point where they want to do one
every year with the spin-off films they
basically have different directors for
the main films and the spin-off films
Brian Johnson is actually taking over
once they get to Episode eight even
though JJ Abrams is still gonna be
producer all say is Empire Strikes Back
still my favorite Star Wars film one of
the only ones to not be directed by
George Lucas regardless of what you
think about episode 7 the guy that
directed brick and looper is gonna be
doing episode 8 and riding it too I'm a
huge fan of his I cannot wait to see
what he turns out so right now you
should actually rewatch those movies
brick was like the small indie movie
that he started with looper is just the
most recent big one that he did one of
the things that makes me really hopeful
about Lucasfilm is that they're picking
non mega directors like Spielberg and JJ
Abrams from all these future films it's
just because the newer people have fresh
interesting ideas about the Star Wars
universe like they have a new take on it
without completely throwing away what
made you fall in love with the
characters so just get excited for
seeing a Star Wars movie that doesn't
look like any kind of Star Wars movie
you've ever seen before so I'm already
doing weekly Star Wars videos now for
rebels but if there's anything from the
movies or anything specific you guys
want to talk about you want specific
bonus videos be sure to leave me all
your requests in the comments and
subscribe to get everything
I'm really excited to talk about more
Star Wars stuff I've waited to do a lot
of movie videos just because they
haven't released a lot of official
information about the movie once we
start getting trailers and actual
footage and stuff from the movie it'll
just be a lot easier cuz we'll actually
have something real to talk about right
now because I post my rebel's videos on
Tuesdays that's probably just gonna
continue to be my Star Wars video day
but in case you haven't seen it you can
click here to learn all about the
potential villains in episode 7 mild
spoiler warning
and you can click here to catch up on
rebels thank you so much for watching so
let's all high five and I'll see you
guys tonight